any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
hey everybody have you ever wondered
what it's like to be an astrophysicist
and get paid
to answer some of the most interesting
exciting
fascinating mesmerizing questions in the
universe
first of all is that true because i
think a lot of people would
would love to have that as their day job
but as their night job perhaps they'd be
even more thrilled
to be able to bring discoveries about
the cosmos
including current events happenings
astronomical
phenomena to the public and have an
audience of
millions of people and to to have a very
thriving
presence online on instagram on youtube
on twitter
and i'm speaking of none other than dr
becky aka dr rebecca smethurst
who is my guest today on the into the
impossible podcast so first of all
i'm looking at you becky and now i can
verify it's really you
because i thought you got a little tick
today i'm sorry about your tick
in most cases how's your tick how's your
day my tick is great
yeah i've i've never thought i'd get a
tick you know it's so weird that like
the
smallest of things can cause so much joy
it's so weird what we've put like
currency in online right but i was like
i so we're of course speaking about the
coveted the
vault wanted uh blue check mark or i
guess it's a great check mark or some
kind of a check mark on
on youtube uh verifying that dr becky
is indeed who she is she's surpassed the
hundred thousand subscriber mark
i am one of those subscribers actually i
have about six of those if you include
all my kids and my wife and everything
uh we all have separate accounts so we
make up a substantial fraction of your
fan base
uh of course uh dr becky is an oxford
university astrophysicist she's a
popular youtube personality
and she's the author of this awesome new
book which uh which i love for very many
reasons becky first of all i don't have
that much time
uh to read books especially about like
stuff in my field
which is astrophysics i should be
actually doing astrophysics but this bug
is irresistible you cannot put it down
it has a gravitational
field that pulls on one's heart and i
want to start off with the book
what caused you to write this
fascinating book i'm talking about space
at the speed of light
yeah um to be honest i have no idea
because i thought i would
never read like never write a book right
i read so many books i
would never write one because i was told
in high school that i was a terrible
writer right
because i write the way that i speak yes
which supposedly
during high school english was not a
good thing to my teacher but
apparently to a publisher and to a like
a public audience
like that's what they love so i got
somebody reached out to me from a public
publisher company in the uk and said you
know we love the stuff you do on youtube
like it's really easy to follow and like
make it fun like we thought about
writing a book i was like
no but they sort of convinced me to do
it and i actually really enjoyed writing
it in the end um
yeah i think it was just you know coming
up with the concept is that it's sort of
ten
short chapters and it's sort of like the
things that if you were going to a
dinner party of astrophysicists
say like me and you were having a dinner
party with like i don't know three or
four of your listeners and they wanted
to know like what what are the 10 things
that i
should know about space at least it's
sort of like the
the base level so that i could you know
get by in a conversation you know around
a dinner table
like that was the sort of idea and it
was you know really fun to just think of
like
what are the things that i think would
blow people's minds
to read about and you know they they
sort of wanted it in the style of carlo
revelli if you
if you've read any of his books um you
know like the seven brief lessons on
physics
and i was like he's very elegant and
eloquent
and i was like i'm more um
over excitable than elegant and eloquent
and so
there's there's a lot of over excitement
in there there's you know references to
mean girls and christmas films and all
sorts but oh
gosh it was fun to write yeah it comes
through in the book
and you know it's but it's fitting that
you mentioned the acknowledgments
and the acknowledgements you mentioned
that you were told by this high school
english teacher that you weren't a good
writer that you wrote the way you talk
and i wanted to actually start there
because i think
that's a huge asset for people like you
yeah
to be able to communicate and to share
things at the level you know i often get
this and and tell me what you feel about
this and someone says
can you dumb it down for me what do you
what do you feel like when somebody says
can you dumb down you're such a
brilliant astrophysicist and that
is true everybody out there you can look
her up on goo i mean she is really
becky your phenomenal output your role
model for both men and women uh
throughout throughout the world of
astronomy uh but what do you say to
somebody when they say can you dumb it
down for me
uh i wanna get your take out i'll give
you my take if you're interested
yeah i i really hate that phrase dummy
because i think is what a science
communicator you're trying to do
is to not remove any of the complexity
of the
of the topic or whatever it's just that
you're trying to get it across in a way
that someone will understand right
like you can take sort of like
einstein's theory relativity and you
could communicate between
astrophysicists and being like here's
what it means
just by giving them an equation and like
someone would understand that because
that's a language they're used to right
it's the language of maths and tenses
and vexes and all that kind of stuff you
learn and
if you do a degree in physics but if you
come across like
you know joj in public on the street
you're not gonna like give them an
equation
but you're not dumbing it down by
expressing that
in different words at the same time
right and so that's what i try and do is
is still
keep the level of complexity and like if
you if you if i need i'll i'll build it
up with
with you know the concepts you need
underlying that but again in like the
simplest way i can
and i've always in the back of my mind
i've always got my mom right
my mom is like you know she she did high
school three phds and astrophysics
relativistic particles no
so she did high school and then and then
left at sort of 16 which is the a.g
can't leave high school in the uk
and um and and that was it but she's
always been like interested
and intelligent but never educated right
because there's a difference between
intelligence
and and educated right and and and i
think i always think as long as my mum
would understand what i'm saying
then i think i'm good
when i describe you and i'm talking to
someone i'm talking to somebody who's
not an
expert scientist talking to my wife i
say she's basically like a drug pusher
for the gateway drug of astronomy you
know like you make it so
i mean it's just your enthusiasm is
irrepressible and i think that
does entice people and then before they
know it they're like slipping down this
this you know wormhole of excitement but
you're not making it like
you know i shouldn't use the word worm i
actually hate when people talk about
wormholes and
time warps and oh there's you know
there's parallel universes and
um i love to think about those things
but i'm an experimentalist
and i like to deal with things that you
can actually touch and divine and
and not not have to come up with so much
pure speculation
and what you do in this book is
remarkable because you actually
introduce as gateway drug pushers would
do
uh you introduce things like galaxies i
mean these are very advanced topics in
astronomy and i want to ask you first
you know what um what to what do you
attribute the
power of astronomy uniquely so to
captivate the public it's not like i
mean our colleagues down the hall for me
from you
uh you know they're studying you know
topological insulators and pneumatic
fluids
i mean they're doing hard stuff
interesting stuff i'm sure but how come
people
don't care as much about that as they do
about the stuff that you do
yeah it's so funny that you describe it
as sort of like the drug pushes like
because i've always called it a gateway
science right because and i think the
reason is because we have the pretty
pictures
right the pretty pictures is what draws
people in and then people get so curious
to know what's in those pretty pictures
that they'll stop and
and listen you know we we have like the
perfect
pr and marketing department just in the
universe itself right
like all the things that we can observe
with telescopes and everything and i
think that really
plays into it but that i think it's more
the fact that like people
are so genuinely curious about
what is our place in the universe and
you know
why almost like why are we here these
big philosophical questions that
you know humanity has always asked that
i think you know physics and
astrophysics are starting to be able to
answer you know in the past sort of
century or so and i think that's what
draws people in the most is that it
it feels like these are the big
questions
right and that's what really grips them
once you've once they've seen the pretty
picture you can then grip them and go oh
but did you know
like that this amazing galaxy that we've
seen so many billions of years ago
can you know tell us this about the
universe and that's the sort of
mind-blowing moment is that connection
that they never necessarily realized and
i love it when you see people make that
connection as well and
you see it in their eyes and then i'm
like they're hooked for life now
and when you uh think about the the
tools that we have i always i agree with
you 100
i would say you know astronomy is the
only subject that people are born with
the
equipment that they need to do it namely
these two refracting until i just took
one of them out with my pokemon
but uh but most of us have two eyes and
there are little tiny refracting
telescopes and you talk about
you know how astronomy evolved in this
book you give a very
concise um history and treatment of
astronomy but you really do take it up
to
the the present day with things that
were really unexplored until citizen
scientists really
started to engage and i think that takes
it one level above the gateway
into the actual practicing scientists so
for many years you you know
uh the people have been doing great work
as amateur astronomers
in uh contributing to discoveries of
comets uh
and and asteroids things of that nature
and
also doing great work in variable star
research but now
uh we have things like galaxy zoo and
these aurora projects that you talk
about can you say something about the
proliferation of that because
that i think it's a little bit different
than just oh i'm interested and excited
to know about
this black hole at the center of the
milky way yeah sure i mean i love what
you said there about you know everyone
is born with the the tools to astronomy
first of all you know i
i like to think of it as you know the
most sort of affluent areas in the world
are actually the people who are
at the most disadvantaged for doing
astronomy right because it's where all
the light pollution is and so
it's this great idea that you know
people who are necessarily considered
you know less economically well-off can
enjoy this so much more and i love the
fact that you know for those who
who don't necessarily have the night sky
that they can enjoy or for those
who who really do get so captivated by
these questions
and want to get involved themselves
citizen science is a way for them to do
that you know
okay necessarily sort of going out in
the garden observing with your telescope
every night trying to discover an
asteroid
because i think sometimes that is what
drives people that sort of desire to
discover
something but the idea that you know i
need help doing my phd
but there's so much data that
you know me and my colleagues that
physically isn't enough of us to go
through it all
and so you know the idea that 300 000
people around the world could help you
with your phd
is incredible and so i always you know
sort of
lord citizen science whenever i can
because
you know i've written papers where
there's me and maybe like eight
collaborators from oxford nottingham you
know
chicago minnesota you know wherever in
the world sydney or something like that
and then 300 000 other people you know
and it's like this work would not be
possible because all of these people
went to a website
they saw an image of a galaxy and they
were asked is it spiral shaped or is it
round and blobbish which is such an
easy question you know because image
recognition is one of those things we
can do
from like a toddler right it's one of
those things that we learn as children
and so
getting people involved in that kind of
science with the knowledge that you know
this science and this result and this
discovery you know wouldn't be possible
without them i think is incredible and i
there's a great story out the back of
one of the projects so one of the
projects was asking people to look
through um planet data and
uh the kepler space telescope data and
it was basically sort of like we're
looking at stars
and if the star's brightness dips there
might be a planet there
so can you record for us if the
brightness is dipping anywhere
and it was such a great project and so
many people got involved the idea that
you could discover
a planet you know around another star in
our milky way that was
obviously people absolutely loved that
and
there did end up being someone who had
discovered a planet that like computer
algorithms had missed in the data
and he was a guy from the northeast of
england retired guy
and the media descended on his house
right and we're like
why did you get involved in this like
incredible project like what was it was
it the discovery that like
drove you to to do this and he was like
well there's only so much gardening you
can do and there's just not a lot on
telly lately
just this retired guy and they're like
do you think you'll you've caught the
bug do you want to catch another one he
was like no probably not i'll probably
do something different
you know and it's just that you can find
so many different people that do it as a
way to
you know spend some time or spend some
time on their commute doing something
useful
rather than angry birds or something i
don't know or
or you know perhaps maybe they find
themselves in a position
where they're not able to contribute to
society in the way that they usually
would either through illness or
an accident or something like that and
we've had so many testimonials from
people just saying
thank you it gave me purpose while i was
recovering you know to know that what i
was spending my time doing was
useful to someone somewhere whether it
was you know classifying the shapes of
galaxies or
the shapes of craters on mars or
flagging where there are penguins and
images from antarctica
you know these huge raft of different
cities and science projects and it's
it's yeah it's a tool to get people into
it but it's also a tool to let them be
involved in science themselves
yeah i just want to correct you that
angry birds is actually high class
ornithological research of course i i'm
so sorry
the ongoing war that we have between
pigs and birds
uh so there are a lot of very cute and
serendipitous connections in the book
between things that have happened here
in san diego
and also your recent video are not too
recent but but
over the summer maybe it was about women
astronomers so first of all i think
you're a collaborator with one of our
former post-docs and uh
proud proud uh that uh you know former
alumnae in some sense of uc san diego
that's brooke simmons
and so say hi i will i have visited
brooke so many times in san diego when
she lived there because
why would i not make the excuse to fly
to california whenever we need to do
this science and i
i'm still welcome back i remember
the the frozen yogurt shop which the
physics departments were outside of and
i was like leave me here
and then also they were testing the
earthquake
plate yes last time i was at ucsd
exactly right outside the physics
building and no one warned me so as a uk
person who has never experienced an
earthquake properly like in her life
like the whole building started shaking
and i was like diving under the desk
like is this what i'm supposed to do
it's really fun to be here to be putting
together a detector and then all of a
sudden an earthquake starts happening oh
gosh
just looked at me so like what are you
what are you doing it's a test and i was
like how am i supposed to know
that in california i'm so close to the
san andreas fault i'm diving on a desk
so
we do that for you you know it's like
when i went to london it was like
perfectly sunny there was no fog and i
was like told my host did queen mary
can't you you know arrange for some fog
while i'm here i mean come on give me
things
so becky we wanted you to have that full
experience thank you i appreciate it
so we also have deeper connections in
the sense that we've had uh
my late great unfortunately she passed
away but margaret burbidge
was here for many years she actually
founded the astronomy group
and she tutored a young scientist by the
name of vera rubin and taught her a lot
about the spectroscopic work that you
talk about in the book
so i think it's a really nice thing to
have this connection and
uh we also have you know to my mind one
of the few if only physics departments
is named after
a female uh nobel prize winner in this
case maria goeppert mayer
who is the only nobel prize winning
female for 50 60 years
until uh just in 2018 when donna
strickland won
so we have a very proud heritage of that
i want to ask you if you're
interested or comfortable would you like
to say anything about you know being a
woman in astronomy how
you see things changing or things
getting better
is the advent of technology like youtube
and so forth
helping or hurting the cause of of you
know kind of increasing diversity and
inclusion in astronomy
yeah i mean i am one of the lucky ones
and that i have never experienced at
least
face to face the sort of
the view that like i wasn't welcome
anywhere i went
you know because of my gender um and i'm
sure i mean there are definitely some
everyday sexism things that you
experience
like i'm sure women listening will know
for from sort of any walk of life
whether it is in an academic department
or outside of it
um but i'm very lucky in the fact that i
don't think i've necessarily been
uh held back by perhaps someone
in a position in power over me who who
is particularly
sexist or misogynist thankfully
um but i am very aware that there's this
sort of
prevailing view that like women like
myself online
are only to young girls
and in the sense that like you know you
have to see yourself to become it and
thankfully i was stubborn enough that i
didn't need to
to do that but to become an
astrophysicist i was just like i just
want to do it so i did it
um and but i'm very aware that that is
necessary for a lot of people but i'd
hope
that by getting in front of both you
know just any young people
that it shows them that women can do
this whether they are young girls or
boys so i loved at the beginning of the
podcast he said you know inspiration to
both men
and women everywhere and that's really
nice of you to say because that's what
i'm hoping to do and also to just
normalize the fact that there is this
weird viewpoint in
that you have to not be feminine
to be in the sciences you know you have
to suppress
that femininity to be whether it's a
physicist or an engineer or whatever it
is or a mathematician
and and sort of um you know not care
about how you look or
your nails or whatever it is and i'm
like no i want my nails to look nice
colors when i'm typing away at my
keyboard like
doing python codes you know to discover
you know these mysteries about black
holes and galaxies so
you know i try and and just showcase
that some more and i hope that by being
on youtube which is one of these um
platforms that it's so
you know young people dominated that
that gets that message out there a
little bit more
and shows that you know there's nothing
that's mutually exclusive with being a
scientist you know
um and that's my big mantra and i hope
that it can do that i worry that the
youtube algorithm is very sort of
self sort of circular in a way and it
sort of says oh you know logging on
you're an 18 year old woman
you'll want to see all the things that
other 18 year old women want to watch
and
even if they necessarily might be
interested in space they would never get
like
recommended it necessarily and that
that's what worries me slightly
out of curiosity as someone who aspires
to the success that you've had
on that platform when you look at your
analytics what does it say i mean mine
is like 95 percent
women sorry i wish
yeah what's my secret uh click here to
subscribe to my newsletter and course
um no it's like 95 male even though i've
tried to have
on you know almost 50 50 and not not
because i'm trying to do so
but because you know our profession is
blessed by the fact that unlike a lot of
other sub disciplines
there are so many successful brilliant
authors and predominantly i'm
interviewing authors but i've got
authors with with african americans
uh you know with with um men women etc
uh lgbtq i don't care but i find it very
hard to move that needle and i'm not
saying oh get rid of the men i don't
want them
but you know i do you have any you know
insight into your own demographics in
your audience
yeah so um i'm i started probably
started off it was similar
and and the more it's grown the more i
think it has reached more girls so
on a good vid like some my highest
percentage on a video has been about 30
women um but on average it's more like
15 percent
um and that's the thing i like when you
say you don't want to get rid of the men
you just want to bring in the girls as
well right you don't want to
rob them of of like this incredible
you know sort of like view of what our
place is in the universe and that
understanding of that you know
because you know historically they have
been more interested in in other topics
or whatever
more interested in other topics because
society said that they should be more
interested in the topics right
because there's that like sort of um
there's the often parroted phrase of
like
oh men and women just have different
interests and it's like yeah but did you
consider the fact that like hundreds of
years of societal oppression on women
might have contributed to your
view of the fact that men and women have
different interests because
most people i talk to they're not
they're not bothered they think it's
really cool whoever i talk to right so
it's that kind of thing that you that
barrier you're trying to overcome and so
much of that sort of
stereotypical behavior is ingrained in a
lot of the algorithms that now control
our sort of you know everyday life from
what we watch on netflix and youtube to
what we listen to on spotify to what we
read on
amazon through the kindle app or
whatever it might be you know it's like
even if we didn't teach these algorithms
that
you know say for example the one that's
come up so much recently with all the
black lives matter protests and
everything has been like you know i read
a lot of sci-fi
and fantasy and it's like you've read a
lot of sci-fi and fantasy by white
authors therefore i'm going to just
you know show you some more and i'm like
you want to
i don't care but somehow that's been
ingrained in
sort of the algorithms because it's
learned that like the this set of people
like this set of authors and this set of
people like this set of authors and it's
just it's like how do you
how do you break out of that and i think
it's the same issue in terms of like
gender and in the sciences as well it's
how do we
sometimes break out those algorithms
that are controlling a lot of what we
actually
what content we actually do you know
yeah and then there's also the overly
simplified analysis i had katie mac on
astr kdm twitter very
prolific social media personality as
well as a top-notch theoretical
astrophysicist and when i had her on my
show for my
uh about six months eight months ago it
was before her book came out but she was
talking about this problem and also
talking about as kind of a burden in the
sense that i'll get to in a second but
she first said you know
there's always these oversimplified
solutions like oh get a pink circuit
board and then the girls will really
love it it's
like she was at cal tech like she
doesn't need that
she wants the heart and that's why i i
think what you do is is unique and
uh in terms of you you talk about
current events you talk about deep
concepts you don't water it down
i think you have to respect your
audience and that's what i liked about
your book you don't dumb it down and
there were things in there that i
learned uh even though i've been you
know
doing astrophysics for you know the
better part of my in the last 30 years
uh there's tidbits that are just like
really curiosity stoking and i think
that's the real difference you know is
that there's a different level perhaps
of curiosity that you have to stoke and
when you get these students you have to
get them at the right age and you have
to nourish them
throughout i've been trying to lend a
little bit you know i have the square
root of your you know followers etc
you know so it's it's not really the
same but yeah i'll lend my pl i'll just
say here's a guest post from an
african-american theoretical physicist
and he can do the post he can do the
video
and i think you know um it's it's a
different format mine's more kind of
interview
rather than uh and conversation based
rather than solo which i think is
is an exceptional part of what you do so
well
but um but i also feel like there's a
burden on women and minorities too from
my my friends that are african-americans
uh you know throughout the world
or throughout the country that are in
different branches of physics
you know they're always and constantly
asked to serve on committees about the
status of minorities and then do
outreach and then do this and do that
and
they get some you know they get some
support from the universities but
do you find it's almost like an added
burden that female astronomers in
particular that are trying i mean you
have a lot of research that you do
how do you how do you find the time to
do the outreach the research and
um and also to do this inclusivity work
that you do exceptionally well
oh it's a massive juggling act yeah and
that's that's the real issue is that you
know we're
we're asked to be on hiring committees
and you know all and
outreach committees and minority and
diversity and everything and it's so
important
to to be invited and to have that seat
at the table
but it's then that you're you know
you're not left alone to just do your
research you know the the cis white man
who's not necessarily wants to be
involved all these things and doesn't
think it's their problem
let's you know is able to just carry on
with their research and then they have
all of the great papers and then they
win all the prizes still and it's just
self
you know just it's a circle again and so
it's it's a little bit difficult knowing
that a little bit difficult juggling it
but
you know i get the emails that remind
you why it was all worth it you know
from
some 14 year old kid somewhere around
the world that's been inspired to become
an astrophysicist because they've
finally seen a woman do it and they
needed that and i'm like
brilliant or it doesn't have to be from
a girl around the world it can be from
any kid around the world you know and
it's just or even
you know someone who's 10 years into a
career and decided to change careers
somewhere as well you think wow
that you can have that big of an impact
in someone's life it reminds you
why you're you're doing all this and why
you're doing all the juggling as well
and you know it's weird because we've
been saying i was speaking to i'm very
very lucky at oxford to
get to have like jocelyn bell benell
just like down the corridor um
who is the the woman who you know
discovered pulsars during her phd and
you know her supervisor won the nobel
prize for it which is you know she
she doesn't seem to be you know angry
about but there's a lot of contention
around
the academic community for and um but
you know conversations with her about
how she's been staying you know
back where in the 50s they were saying
it it will change because we we'll get
into positions of power and it will
change and we're still
saying that same thing it's like the
same rhetoric and you just wonder what
you know what it is
what is it and i think it is really sort
of i remember seeing a fantastic talk
about someone who who wasn't studying
astronomy and had been dragged into this
sort of diversity debate it was they
were actually studying in the
netherlands somewhere they were studying
the gender balance in academia in
general
right and it was like the ways that we
can fix it and that was their research
right it wasn't someone who has like
gotten caught up in it and thought oh in
my spare time i'll do this like we have
spare time right so
they gave a talk about it and and what
it really comes down to is is two things
it comes down to those societal
expectations of gender
which get ingrained in kids from about
seven years old
so if you want you know girls to pick
physics and more boys to pick
you know nursing or whatever it is
that's the more traditionally female
route
then you you need to get through to them
at seven years old not
you know 14 or 16 or whatever it is and
the other thing is
is the way that we just treat careers in
academia you know it's that sort of like
the lone wolf scientist that you know
takes two days off for the birth of
their first child
and that's it you know in their life and
just cracks on with research
and it's like no nobody's life is like
that now in modern day like 21st century
right
most people are living you know if they
have a partner it's usually dual income
households
it's you know the part the the father
usually wants to take you know
shared maternity leave with the mother
and we need to restructure
careers with respect to modern day
familial life you know however that
might look for people and
career breaks and you know career gaps
and the the freedom to go and do
separate things while you do research
and stuff and that's what it comes down
to
and until that changes i don't i don't i
think we'll keep saying you know
oh eventually we'll have you know more
women in permanent positions and more
minorities in permanent positions
and it's just like there is bigger
like issues that are stopping that from
happening right that affect everybody
so yeah i want to turn before we get
back to the book
and um and discuss the questions i like
to ask all my victims i mean guess
um let's talk about one of the papers i
looked at that's uh one of your
higher sided papers uh that you're the
first author on so first of all can you
explain to someone who might not know
what does it mean to be a first author
how does such things get chosen
um when you're working with with people
that are also very eminent like brooke
and and and christian et cetera how do
you get to do
uh become the so-called first author and
we're talking specifically about galaxy
zoo the interplay of quenching
mechanisms in the group environment
sure yeah so um that really is usually
like you know
whose idea was it first sometimes it's
like if it was your idea and you ran
with it then it's kind of your baby and
you're the first author you write it up
but sometimes it might be that you're a
postdoc you know more senior and you'll
have an idea but you won't have the time
to do it so you'll sort of say
to a phd student you know have you
thought about doing this like this would
be a great project for you
and then they'll run with it and and
then they'll be the first author so
usually the rule of thumb that i take is
like who who's done the most work
right and then if it's really 50 50 then
whose idea was it that it's their baby
then right
um and then and therefore like they're
gonna write it up so so this paper that
you're talking about was part of my phd
and so like um the idea for my whole phd
obviously came from my supervisor
because that's what happens in the uk
you apply for a specific project and
sort of the project is then yours to do
what you will with it that's the idea is
that you take
it in whatever direction you'd like
because it's independent research
obviously a phd so this was like the
last project and this was really like
i want to do this with this data that we
have available
and so that was like why it was my sort
of first author paper and everybody else
who's
listed as an author is like my
collaborators who
you know during the process i would go
into their office and i would
uh you know turn up with a plot and i'd
be like this is a plot i've got and i'm
thinking it's telling me this but like
what do you think and i would just like
bounce ideas off them and we would you
know have sort of like a back and forth
and
it's one of the things i love most about
my job to be honest is just making a
plot and wandering into someone's office
or
someone's zoom call at the minute and
just be like what are you seeing and we
just bounce
ideas back and forth about what it could
mean in terms of like the big picture of
the universe like when you put it that
way it's like
mind blown um and so like that's that's
what it really means right is that is
that you're the one like leading
the interpretation and and you're the
one making the plots and writing the
code and really doing the grumpy work
and so this paper in particular is
interesting to me because it suggests
sort of a
decently long time scale you know
comparable to the age of the sun for
example
for objects uh at a decent distance that
you
kind of cross correlate these different
uh spectral
and energy uh regime data from from
galax to
sdss et cetera um so this this
what would you say is the most
surprising thing was it related to the
time scale for this quenching first of
all what's quenching
yes does it mean you know it's hot the
day in the summertime you go down to the
pub or what does this mean
main focus in my research is this idea
of quenching and it's this idea that
galaxies are these islands of stars you
know hundreds of billions of stars right
and they have gas available to make new
stars
but as like other stars die you know
over the sort of millennia well
millennia maybe millions of years i
guess to billions of years and so the
the question is like if a galaxy has a
constant supply of gas will it just keep
on forming stars right or if you
cut off that supply of gas what's going
to happen to it right is it going to
stop
forming stars how will it stop forming
stars very very quickly will it stop
forming stars very very slowly
like how fast is it going to use up that
remaining gas or how fast is it going to
get rid of that gas
and therefore what processes are
actually doing that right like
and so one of my main focuses of my
thesis was understanding how like
supermassive black holes could
contribute to this
and one of sort of the ideas behind that
was that
well it depends like what environment
you're in are you in a very dense
environment surrounded by lots of other
galaxies or are you in a very like
under-dense environment where they've
been relatively left alone
and so i wanted to sort of piece this
out of what was going on so that i could
understand
better what was going on with the black
holes like what role did these black
holes play i couldn't piece that out
until i knew what role the environment
was playing and so i did this big study
on sort of like okay let's take into
account how big the galaxies are how
massive they are
and take into account how many sort of
nearest neighbor galaxies do they have
and let's take into account
uh what shape the galaxy is as well
because the shape of the galaxy which is
where the sort of classifications from
galaxies you come in
really sort of tells us what's happened
in the galaxy's past
that we can't necessarily see in any
other sort of clue
about the galaxy so for example if a
galaxy
has a sort of big blob-ish shape rather
than a spiral shape we'll think that
it's had a merger with another galaxy at
some point in its history so that tells
us a lot too
and so what i was trying to do was sort
of by saying okay
from how bright these galaxies currently
are
in the uv light which is probes you know
very recent stars that have formed to
sort of more optical reddish light which
probes sort of the older generation of
stars can we unpiece
what rate the galaxy is for big stars at
is it like
top rate is it slowing down has it
slowed down very quickly
like what's happened here and so one of
the surprising things yes was how slow
these processes might actually happen
especially in galaxies that have been
left alone because we sort of thought
galaxies left alone
they'll just keep happily forming stars
you know
contently and until until something
happens to them but actually they can
sort of shoot themselves in the foot
and like do things that mean that their
gas is used up
you know from stuff they do internally
to themselves
and but that can happen so so slowly and
that can get confused with the sort of
stuff that black holes tend to cause as
well which is really intriguing
but i think the main thing that came
from that paper was that
you know that everyone for maybe the
past 20 30 years they've been studying
this have been sort of saying you know
what one mechanism is causing this right
for this type of galaxy
then you know this mechanism is the one
thing that makes it stop
forming strawberries and for this type
of galaxy there's this one process that
makes it stop forming stars
and from what i concluded it was just
like actually there's this like
i don't know conspiracy or cohort of
quenching processes that are all like
collaborating and working together
and all affecting a galaxy at some point
in its life
to sort of keep it you know from from
forming more stars and you know it's not
just one thing they're all
in cahoots with each other basically and
and i love this idea that
you know this is probably why we're
struggling to find evidence of like
black holes stopping forming stars which
siri
says they should do for ages and we're
still searching for observational
evidence of it and that's one of the
things i'm doing now
and it's like why is it so elusive this
evidence it's probably because it's
mixed up with all this other stuff why
is it so hard to find about these things
that existed billions of years ago and i
located billions
it should be so easy yeah i know and
yeah it's just not because there's just
so many things that have just
got in the way i guess and and neither
sort of masqueraded as this effect or
maybe even drowned out the effects of
this other thing we're looking for and
so it's it's a really interesting piece
of work actually i really like it
um yeah it's a very yeah it's a very
readable paper i looked at a few of the
papers that had to do with feedback and
you know
have to look for my my former co-worker
brooks work and
and the interplay between both the
interaction that you guys have uh
or with the the data not not only from
galaxy zoo and the citizen science that
of course is a story in itself
um literally i mean christian has
stories about that
uh but but the work that you and brooke
do on agn and black holes and the
interaction
and the feedback mechanisms and star
form i mean these are the biggest topics
that
anybody can study and there's so much
more left to know as you talk about the
different knowns unknowns etc
[Music]
i always ignore the advice that people
say don't judge a book by its cover and
i always judge books by their cup
and now i also judge books by their
weight their mass and this one's so nice
because it's it's so
it's so portable uh it literally fits in
a big enough pocket but
tell us about the cover the title what
does it mean
who came up with it how'd you think
about it what does it mean well funnily
enough
it's got two different titles in the uk
in the us which is
yeah frustrating for someone who's like
a global you know sort of social media
presence
right um but yeah so in the uk it was
where the first title was sort of like
space 10 things you should know you know
it was based on the idea of potential
essays and
it was sort of very concise and in the
u.s they thought they wanted to go with
more of the idea of the fact that it was
a quick read you know that it is so
short
and that it's very digestible and they'd
really
the main thing i didn't want to do with
this book was make it so long that it
put
people off especially beginners who are
new to this kind of topic
um but we're still interested but we're
like oh i'm
that that's too smart for me and
whatever and it's like that's that's
ridiculous right like it's written
for you know anyone to enjoy but
particularly the fact that it was sort
of like a
you can dip your toe into this with a
quick read and so they really like the
idea of um space at the speed of light
you know it's kind of a little pun of
sort of like you know you can read it
really quickly the fastest speed there
is almost
so uh and also that i speak really
quickly and i'm known
for speaking quickly i guess it sort of
has a part on that too so
i really like the subtitle of the book
though it's um 14 billion years for
people short on time
right it's like the history of the
universe the big things in the history
of the universe that you
you know you want to find out and uh and
sort of like you say
be like yourself you know not much time
because you've got so much other stuff
going on but you're still interested
um the cover i think i i love both
covers the uk cover is shiny
which it just appeals to my magpie
tendencies which i love you know it's
like
blue and shiny but the the american
version is um the north north american
version i should say because it's us and
canada
um is like blue and coppery color
yeah and like i'm a millennial and i
fully embrace the millennial and i'm
just like
look at how beautiful it looks it looks
beautiful on a coffee table especially
like you guys i don't know if you listen
as we see behind me but i have a blue
wall
you know it was like copper accents it's
very like millennial pinterest and i
just
i love it so much and i love the fact
that it can be this like
beautiful piece like on someone's
bookshelf as well that will really add
to that
um it's extremely readable also the
illustrations are just delicious
yes actually literally delicious look
what i'm uh using this is
this is a hot sauce that i enjoy
sometimes it's called truth so
i actually was using it uh but the
illustrations are delightful
justin van genderant yeah justin van
genderen did those who is an incredible
artist and
he what the vibe was for those
illustrations was sort of these um
like the nasa like vintage posters that
they made for sort of to kepler 51b
yeah yeah yes exactly and like i
i that was the sort of the vibe was that
it would be both scientifically
sort of accurate in the sense of a data
visualization but still beautiful
in the fact that they were artwork you
know um and like i'm hopefully gonna get
one of them framed and stuff which i'm
really excited for
and you know it does have that sort of
right and also one of the things i love
about it
is that all the illustrations are blue
and red yes
you've noticed that they're all blue and
red it's the aesthetic yeah
yeah and and the idea is that is that
it's sort of blue shift direction
right mm-hmm and you actually talk about
doppler and the doppler shift as well
very very readable explanation of that
thank you yeah
so yeah blue blue blue shift and red
shift and sort of that sort of spectrum
of light across the universe
was the idea and i loved that play with
color i thought it was great yeah
it's really delightful and you know
another fun thing about it is and this
is no disrespect to your
uh to your massive wonderful paper but
that paper is about 18 pages give or
take
that we just discussed about quenching
and it took me as long to read that as
to read this entire book
you know where i check off on my list of
books read in 2020
i don't check off the papers but the
thing that appealed to me so
much we already talked about the
acknowledgements and how you acknowledge
kind of this
this high school teacher uh and what
struck me in the paper i just have to
mention it
like you acknowledge an anonymous
referee i mean
that is very um to me that's that's
pretty worthy of respect because a lot
of times
we just assume and we cultivate this
image that we astronomers you know we
know everything we can do everything and
in both cases
both your teacher was wrong for
underestimating you or not valuing
this skill set that you have i always
say like i mean you're kind of a
stand-up comedian in some ways too
and that's that's actually very
difficult skill stuck because
you have to know a little bit about
persuasion a little bit about sales
you know the ability to sell an idea
aesthetics as we were just talking about
um artistically
but you know one thing that's not really
taught is sort of you know how do you
put all those
individual skills together and we know
many astronomers who are
you know can can do more calculations or
have done more observations and there's
so much superhuman
but very few people can combine those
skills together so i really appreciate
that you do that you write in an
engaging fashion
both in your you know in your research
work which which is very digestible
but in this book as well i call it in my
review
i forget what i said i said it's as
brief as inflation
but teaming with but teaming with
information and inspiration as our
galaxy
probably teems with life so i want to i
want to finish
with a couple questions that i ask oh my
gosh you call these you know deep
questions i agree with you it's early
here but yeah
maybe you've punched yourself at the pub
already i don't know no not quite i wish
but yeah so ask these questions to
really get a sense from my guests and
give a little bit more of the
personality of course you were you know
well-known person
uh but um but i asked them you know if
you were to leave a will and not a
material will with your vast vast
wealth in your and your presumably you
know your your don't they give you
youtube some kind of plaque or something
unobtainium
built into it no copper for you uh so
you're not going to leave that to
anybody but what wisdom
or you know influential piece of advice
or something would you want to give
to uh to people in the future in
the form of what we call a ethical will
yeah um i guess
so i guess where my mind goes with this
question is like um a sort of dystopian
future where like
all knowledge has been lost like what
would i want to
pass down in the hope that you know we
they could rebuild i guess or something
or like rebuild the knowledge base that
we once had and i
my brain went to the sort of the the
fable what is it that um
you know give amount of fish and you
feed him for a day but you know teach
man to fish and
he feeds himself for a lifetime i was
sort of like what's the astrophysical
knowledge equivalent
that was where i was trying to go to be
like you know what it what is the thing
that i could i could
pass on and i i think that i think i've
decided that it would be
the knowledge of of how to like build
telescopes
so something like the hubble space
telescope or the very large telescope or
something like that in the hope that
if you give them that then they just
rediscover all the things that we know
anyway right because they'd be able to
look out and see
you know uh the stars in the milky way
and then the island universes and
galaxies outsiders is
sort of a camp called them island
universes right we know that galaxies of
hundreds of thousands of stars
hundred billion hundreds of billions of
stars in themselves
um but then also that they'd be able to
do those galaxies recessing and they
come to the conclusion that the universe
started in a big bang and then all of
the sort of benefits that we've then
got in terms of like astronomical
research from you know
uh digital detectors and image analysis
that's fed into medical imaging and you
know wi-fi from
sort of it's getting so frustrated that
they belong to
yeah like literally like didn't so much
in smartphones has come from astronomy
and everyone's like what's the point of
doing astronomy and you're like
well yeah so i think it would be that
kind of stuff right and then there'd be
so much
that would come out of that from from
giving them telescopes i think that
would be the thing it's like i don't
want to
like tell them stuff i want them to
figure it out themselves
yes exactly what you do in your
in your teachings online yes because i
never thought about it that way
you spoke the curiosity and once you
teach the person curiosity
uh then you know he or she can take it
from there and sort of that's the
fishing
versus uh teaching to fish and of course
i as a telescope builder
very much appreciate you astronomers
saying things that are nice about those
of us who build telescopes because often
i won't be able to do it thanks for
building us that thing in the dome over
there
we'll take it from here keating we don't
need you anyway uh
next one is also kind of about the
future but it's more um
it's more about uh sort of uh you know
that's
the the biggest thing that you that you
associate with accomplishments of
humanity perhaps
uh and maybe it's related to what you
just said and this is something um
that a civilization wouldn't necessarily
need to know like how to build a
telescope because they're going to
discover
you know basically a billion years from
now on a monolith
you know on the moon surface or in an
asteroid and this is kind of like in sir
arthur c clarke's 2001
space odyssey now these monoliths are
kind of meant there to be discovered at
certain times and
some people speculate you talk a lot
about life in the universe uh that
you know the moon the surface of the
moon or these these trojan asteroids or
whatever
would be good places to put to put alien
civilizations could have put messages
there for us to find and i guess
what what aspect of you know humankind
uh
it sounds like it would be something
astronomical for you um
do you think are you most proud of you
know there was a famous
picture when einstein died in 1955 i
believe you know time magazine put a
put a cartoon out and there's a picture
of the planet earth the giant billboard
and it said einstein lived here and it
was pointing to
what do you think is like sort of the
greatest accomplishment um and it
doesn't have to be astronomy it could be
literature or whatever you do outside of
astronomy
i don't this is the thing i was trying
to i've been trying to think about this
and
it's it's so difficult because i don't
feel like i'm a good enough judge
outside of like astronomy and
astrophysics of like
what is you know the most important
knowledge that we have
right because it's not my field and i
could pick something that would
you know not be and so i feel like i
only have the
you know the gravitas if you will to
decide what it would be in astronomy or
astrophysics and so my brain went to
sort of like the idea of leave its law
moved up to henrietta to leave it
separate variables
if you have separate variables you can
use them as these sort of standard
candles and figure out distance in the
universe
and so if you have that it's sort of the
bottom rung of the distance ladder we
call it right and you can work out
the next thing that needs to be
calibrated based on leave it floor and
all this kind of stuff and on and on and
on
and i was like maybe that would be the
same you know giving them the first step
on the ladder and then they
again like you know teaching fish kind
of thing it would it would then they'd
be able to take all the steps in a lot
of themselves and
but and trying to think about it in
terms of like all of human
accomplishments ever
like like it's so hard like
go back to the wheel like i presume they
don't have the wheel anybody who's going
to discover this on the surface of an
asteroid so i don't
i almost feel like in a way
if i'm thinking about some either future
human civilization or ancient or you
know
future alien civilization that's gonna
discover something that i can leave on
an asteroid if they're found in an
asteroid they're gonna know more than i
am
right and so it's almost like arrogant
of me to assume that i
could know something that would be
valuable to them
hmm interesting that was that was my yes
would that be
anything like right you know penicillin
i don't know
chemical formula for penicillin
the same question she's the late great
girl sagan's widow
and she actually did it she actually put
her brain waves on the golden disc that
was mounted to the voyager 1 spacecraft
so she's like yeah i've been there i've
done that but she actually told me some
other things so i'll leave that as a
teaser
uh for you to check out my interview uh
channel with her
last question is maybe easier and
doesn't have anything to do with
astronomy necessarily but this is kind
of going now we're going
back to the future no we're going back
to the past we went too far into the
future it's it's
it's uh we did it um what do you think
uh you would tell the 20 year old dr
becky or
pre dr becky uh what would you tell her
a piece of advice that
you once the name of this podcast is
into the impossible and it derives from
sir arthur c clarke's third law which is
the only way to see what is possible is
to venture out into the impossible so
what did you think was impossible
perhaps as a 20 year old
or 30 year old i don't know i actually
don't know how old you are it's so
important
i'm getting over it slowly yeah wow
i i would trade places you know i always
say it's better than the alternative not
getting older uh
so so tell me what would you tell
yourself as
a 20 year old uh uh that you wish you
knew but you found out only because you
had the courage
and the fortitude to go into the
impossible
yeah i i would tell them tell her
that nobody no matter how
successful or put together or
you know career-wise you know whatever
they have
nobody had a plan for her to get there
that's what i would tell you know it
seems like
you know the very organized and
successful people have this like road
map that they were following right but
you know i i feel like there are people
now that would consider you know what i
do
is it i mean i consider it a dream job
like literally i'm doing research and
i'm doing youtube and psychom and then
people like it and it's great it's
literally the dream job
and i'm like i didn't get here because i
wrote out a 10 year plan at 20 year old
or a 5 year plan at 20 year old i got
here because
it was just one decision at a time that
every decision i made was for like yeah
that sounds fun let's do that
you know and that meant that i made
mistakes and mistakes are totally okay
because how else are you supposed to
learn right so i didn't necessarily go
into the impossible but it went into the
unknown
and ended up here right so when i
finished my university undergrad
i was like so lost of what to do right i
loved school and i felt bereft when i
left school
right and so when i got to university i
was like few four years at least now i
like this this is fine
and then the end of that four years i
was like bereft again not knowing what
to do because
i just love learning and that and just
these halls of learning i was just i
want to do this for the rest of my life
and i didn't realize at the time that
going into research meant you will still
be learning for the rest of your life
right because
you're not necessarily being taught it
anymore you're the one figuring out the
answers
you know no one's telling you the
answers anymore you're literally like
writing the textbooks
it's not like solving harder homework
problems right exactly
yeah it's problems that might not have
an answer i mean you didn't know if
you'd finally
answer these questions uh quenching
questions until you actually
did it and you did go into the i mean
think about trying to explain that to
your great great great great
you know grandfather you know uh many
many uh
decades ago they couldn't even
comprehend it so in a way you did go
into the impossible and thanks to arthur
c clarke's first law which is any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic i want
to thank you for
the magic that you do and for writing
this this little slim book that i can
give to anybody now
um and someday you'll have to sign it
when you come back to get some yogurt i
promise
i'm inviting you here to get some yogurt
is not a thing in the uk
oh my god many privations but maybe none
so much as that
uh becky thank you for being an
inspiration to to millions around the
world
and for the awesome science that you do
that keeps us so interested in the
communication of that science
uh that helps us who uh perhaps
um you know are aspiring to do exactly
that know what path to take and to be
someday perhaps a uh get a little tick
just like you someday that's my
i wanna have a tip just like becky
doctor okay
thank you so much have a wonderful
evening over there and i hope to see you
sometime soon in the in the real world
sure definitely
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review
for a chance to win a free copy of our
most recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
[Music]
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san diego
eric vieri director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco